who wants a vaccine by the end of the
second quarter of 2021
as we've continued to make progress on
vaccine development and manufacturing
general purn and his team have been in
close touch with our state partners on
how we will be allocating and
distributing the doses as they become
available
we'll also be releasing more
informational material in the coming
days and weeks for americans to help
spread the word about the safety and
efficacy of the coming vaccines
we also continue to allocate and ship
more courses of the two
authorized antibody treatments to help
americans at risk for severe covid 19
who have not been hospitalized
as of today we have now allocated more
than 278 thousand courses
of these treatments as i've noted in
previous weeks
every american who's recovered from
covid19 in the past three months can
help expand our arsenal of potential
treatments for this virus by donating
plasma
millions of americans have recovered
from covet 19 in the last several months
and could be eligible to donate please
contact your local american red cross or
local american blood bank or go to
coronavirus.gov for more information
about how you can volunteer to be a
donor
and give the gift of life i'll conclude
by reminding all americans that even as
we have such a bright future ahead
we face extremely concerning trends in
the spread of the virus
hospitalization rates are now at the
highest they have been during the
pandemic
we are so close to being able to protect
millions of americans from this virus
with a vaccine
for now we need to double down on the
steps that can keep us all safe the
three w's
wash your hands watch your distance wear
a face covering you can't watch your
distance
and avoid places like indoor settings
and
crowded out crowded settings where you
can't do those things
those public health measures are the
safe bridge to a vaccine
thank you again for joining us and i'll
now hand things over to dr slowly
to give us updates on the vaccine
development front
thank you mr secretary hi everybody so
just a few comments to add and build up
on what
mr secretary has said clearly great
focus
on the fda outcome tomorrow and then and
then
a week from tomorrow uh reviewing the
pfizer
and then the modern vaccines probably
most of you have
now had a chance to look into the pfizer
submission
i'll be happy to address any questions
you may have there but
quite remarkable efficacy i think very
good
safety profile mostly injection site and
injection related
adverse events one of the points i'd
like to attract your attention
attention to is the kaplan mayor curve
that shows that within
12 days or so from the first dose of
vaccine the number of cases
in the study a vaccine arm flattens
and continues to remain flat after the
second dose but the key point is
already after the first dose and if you
study the immunogenicity data you'll see
that there is
barely detectable neutralizing
antibodies at that time
there is already very very significant
uh protection induced i think it's very
important because
hopefully we will start impacting
people's lives very quickly after the
onset of
of the campaigns to immunize and
secondly
it's something that makes us very more
uh
optimistic in regard of the jansen's
vaccine jnj that as you know is being
tested as one
dose vaccine probably in a few days the
moderna
booklet will be published and and
you will see that the the data are as
as impressive and compelling regarding
the
the j j vaccine i said it's a one shot
vaccine actually there is a there is a
second phase three trial that has a two
shots vaccine but
what we consider to be a breakthrough in
terms of intervention into the pandemic
could be the one shot vaccine where
optimistic efficacy could be very high
we have already recruited
more than 38 000 subjects in the study
with j j we decided to cap the
recruitment
to around 40 000 subjects which will
happen
by the end of this week in the next two
three days
and given the attack rate into the study
and in the countries
where the study has been conducted it is
very likely that we will have our first
views on efficacy for this vaccine very
early in the month of january
and that somewhere in the late of the
month of january or early february
an eua would be submitted and hopefully
approved
swiftly we may be able
to accumulate another 30 to 40 million
vaccinees in the month of february if
this vaccine gets approved and an
equivalent number or slightly higher
going forward in the month of march et
cetera so
an important thing to keep in mind uh
in terms of impact on the uh on the
pandemic
also the astrozenica vaccine we have now
about 18 000 subjects recruited in the
u.s conducted phase 3 trial that's
under the oversight of operation war
speed there are no
different dosages there's no different
batches
of vaccine that study we believe
is going to give a clear outcome as to
the efficacy
and safety of the vaccine and we again
look forward to potentially reading out
from that study on its efficacy
somewhere
late in the month of january and if
positive
an eoa may be filed somewhere in late in
the month of uh february with with
final analysis data on the protein
vaccine side which is the third
platform technology as you know that we
have in the portfolio
we have very good progress uh with
novovax
that is gearing up to
start its phase three trial and we have
some further analysis ongoing and
discussions
with san rafi to see what the next steps
in progressing the tri the vaccine
there towards uh uh phase three so
things are uh moving in the right
direction
uh and happy to address your questions
and pass on to
my co-leader general perna to tell you
more about
how these vaccines are going to make it
into people
great thanks dr sally and mr secretary
thank you
uh so uh you know just exciting time to
be
in the business that we're in right now
supporting this through
logistics and eventual sustainment of
vaccine
distribution and and resupply
accordingly
so we are focused on
our micro planning uh at the state
jurisdiction level uh reminder of the
triad that's involved in this
the cdc experts uh who
developed uh the strategy who have been
working day-to-day with the states for
the last six months
the commercial industry partners
mckesson fedex ups
walgreens cvs and many others
who are working their plans every day
to make them better and then of course
the states right
our ability to enable their priorities
and their plans is what really will
determine our success
every day that goes by we get stronger
on this but eventually
right we're going to have uh an eua
right not to get out in front of that
decision but be to be prepared
for it this week this past
friday all the jurisdictions all 64
jurisdictions
and five federal agencies locked in
their micro plans for the pfizer vaccine
so based on their uh their allocation of
vaccine which we provided to them
we locked in 636 locations
by quantity uh vaccine delivery
if and when the vaccine is approved
as i've talked about we will begin
upon approval of eua packing
to the micro plans and distribute begin
distribution within 24 hours
out to the jurisdictions accordingly
our goal is to make sure that we can
ensure the vaccine
is delivered on top in a timely manner
is delivered safely securely
and it's ready to be utilized to start
administering
a vaccine as soon as possible
to that end what we also already did i
gave permission
to already distribute syringes and
needles
alcohol wipes and dilutant which is
required in support of the pfizer
vaccine
we'll begin that today it'll be a
distribution will be completed by friday
again only to set conditions and if it
sits there for
another week or 10 days or whatever then
it does
but planning for success we wanted to
make sure that the states had
all that they needed to have this week
we're focusing not only on the final
planning for the pfizer vaccine but
we're in deep coordination
for the micro plans for the moderna
vaccine
so last night final lock of allocations
were provided to the jurisdictions
today tomorrow and friday they will lock
in locations and quantities
and hence we'll be prepared for
follow-on um uh eventual approval of the
eua for moderna
so great news in the planning world
really confident
in the collaboration by the cdc with the
states
by the continuous improvement by
commercial industry
and then the state's knowledge and
execution of their plans
we continue to uh have conversations
with the public health officials
across the country right we are
personally
talking to them i'm either briefing
governors
with secretary azar and dr salawi
or we are making phone calls
individually to governors
but more importantly helping the health
experts who advise governors on their
plans
you know in the army we call this
battlefield circulation
to assess you know where everybody is
to help focus to add enablers if
required to fine-tune
etc and so we're working this virtual
circulation
uh with everybody very powerful sessions
that it's allowing us to identify things
ahead of time
several calls you know i've said general
they've said general we'd like you to
consider something absolutely
that's why we're calling cdc's up on the
phone commercial industries on the phone
the states are on the phone and we're
solving problems ahead of execution
does this mean perfection no plan is
only good to get you started
what is important is the open
communication and collaboration
between the triad to sustain to develop
plans
get ahead of problems and be ready to
execute really
really appreciate those phone calls
collectively by everybody
finally we're working on education
materials for the vaccine
cdc is doing excellent work they've
already
posted on their web page significant
education
uh uh information and tools for the
pfizer vaccine
uh and how to work through it it will be
updated based on
fda guidance uh and uh the asip guidance
right so it's not the conclusion yet but
it's allowing people to get involved and
start to really see things
so they're not learning things at the
last minute right everything that's
admissible to be
provided is being sent out uh and will
be updated accordingly
really really important piece uh to what
we're doing
so at the end of the day i'm very
excited about where we're at
uh if you're in my profession and you're
not excited you ought to be doing
something else
uh i feel confident that we've done
uh detailed planning we've worked uh
through rehearsals
we have checked the what if box uh and
we continue to learn every day
in preparation for eventual distribution
mr secretary great thank you general
thank you dr
dr slowly and uh michael if you want to
get us started on questions from the
media thank you sir thank you all
operator we will now open it up for
questions and a friendly reminder that
when asking a question please state your
name and publication
and keep your questions as short as
possible so we can get to as many
questions
as we can in the time that we have and
i'll turn it over to you now operator
yes thank you if you would like to ask a
question please press star 1
unmute your phone and record your name
and outlet clearly
if you need to withdraw your question
please dial star 2. again to ask a
question please dial star one
our first question comes from kevin
brown from fox news
kevin your line is open good afternoon
it's it's
evan brown thank you so much um two
questions are really quickly
the uk has reported a few cases of
people
having an allergic reaction and they're
advising some people who know that they
might have allergic reactions to
not get the vaccine is there a similar
request or order
that would come from american
authorities on this uh telling people
hey
you should not get this vaccine and
second of all
when does a an eu a evolve into a more
permanent approval for either these
vaccines or any vaccines in general
great evan i'll let me answer the the
second question
and then i'll pass it to dr slowly to
speak about the the british incident
that's been reported
so in terms of uh eua versus
the full biologic license is called a
bla
this is actually a fairly unique
circumstance here because
the fda has through their eua guidance
on covid vaccines
actually required a very high standard
of data on safety efficacy and
manufacturing compared
actually to what the statute requires
for an emergency use authorization they
are
effectively holding these vaccines
very close to the evidentiary standard
required for a biologic license so for
instance
each clinical trial is required to have
30 000 people in it that's
extremely large for a vaccine clinical
trial
they're requiring 60 days of safety data
from the median patient
visit 90 of adverse events with a
vaccine usually occur within the first
42 days all of the statistical
significance
requirements for efficacy are the same
that they would have been
for a full license so up everything i
just laid out there
is what a manufacturer would have done
for a full-on license there really are
two principal differences between an
emergency authorization as we'll be
seeing here potentially
versus the full biologic license one is
long-term safety data of course of
necessity you don't have years of
data of safety information with a with a
normal product
going through the system because you
wouldn't have had operation warp speed
doing commercial manufacturing at the
same time as the default development
process
you would have had then time for ongoing
safety monitoring before you ever had
vaccine released
here we'll have a extremely aggressive
what's called pharmacovigilance program
which is part of what general purna and
the cdc have orchestrated with our
states
to very aggressively monitor
as more and more people are vaccinated
for any type of safety signals safety
events etc so that's part of that but
again
60 days of patient visit data 90
of adverse events and vaccines usually
within the first 42 days so well within
that window
the second is really around
manufacturing obviously the fda for an
emergency use authorization will be
validating manufacturing quality
to ensure consistency of product from
what was done in the clinical trials to
what's used in commercial scale
for a full on biologic license they
actually will run
trial lots in the manufacturing facility
under fda inspection
that tends to take another several
months
after what now an eua would be that that
comes out so
be thinking approximately four or more
months
after an eua issues that the products
might be subject to a full-on
final biologic license but now dr sawyer
and certainly
correct me as the expert on vaccine
development if i if there's anything you
want to correct on that front
but then on the on the uk issue please i
will
spot on uh mr secretary uh regarding the
uh allergic reactions uh our
understanding is two healthcare workers
who were known to have severe allergic
reactions
in the sense that they had both epipens
on them
and they carry them all the time so that
tells me
they are known to have
severe allergic reactions have had what
has been
termed an anaphylactoid reaction
which which is a systemic as well as
local reaction but not
life threatening and they probably i
assume that i i don't know for a fact
uh injected themselves with the epipen
and and
and therefore the reaction resolved uh
looking into the data
patients or subjects with severe
allergic
reaction history have been excluded from
the clinical trials
which is classic so
my expectation is that this is new news
and i would assume that of course the
fda will make those decisions
that tomorrow this will be part of the
consideration
and as in the uk the expectation would
be that
subjects with known severe reaction
allergic reactions
should not take the vaccine until we
understand exactly what happened here
great thank you we can turn to the next
question please
our next question comes from sarah
overmall from politico
sarah your line is open thank you
i wanted to ask about state's
applications of vaccines
um general partner you said that those
were just finalized
why did certain allocations decreased
before they were finalized and then um
according to this wall street journal
article that was breaking down the
expected allocations
um organs getting roughly the same
amount as alaska when they have six
times the population so if this is done
based on population why are there
numbers like that
okay so uh just maybe a refresher
uh we are allocating uh
by uh by population a prada
to the available vaccine when i snap the
chalk line
vaccine comes off through manufacturing
to fill
finish only when i'm confident that it's
been approved
for final distribution does it count
for us to distribute when i snap the
chalk line
on that number then what we do is we
take the pro
rada population of above 18 years old
we allocate that number and hence we
develop
allocations to all the jurisdictions and
five federal agencies
accordingly so an example the the
pfizer vaccine only had x amount
available that was approved
for distribution when i snapped the
chalk line two weeks ago
because i wanted the states to have time
to do micro planning to that number
a week later when we were talking about
allocating to moderna there was a
different amount available
and i snapped the chalk line we did the
we did the formula and hence they have a
different allocation
it will bounce back and forth week to
week
based on availability of vaccines that
are approved
for distribution but our formula for
distribution remains the same
the states will then prioritize
inside of the eua
fda eua guidance and the cdc
asip guidance and they will figure out
what groups to prioritize inside of that
i think good yeah next question please
our next question comes from angel andre
excuse me angelica levito from bloomberg
news angelica your line is open
thank you for taking my question when
will operation warp speeds publicize the
state and jurisdiction allocations and
if it does not plan to publicize these
why not so
right now we we uh we publicize the
allocations by state
to the states right and so every state
has their allocation
uh to for the distribution of pfizer and
moderna
uh that is a working uh number that
we need to utilize for our planning and
execution
it is based on as i articulated
the pro rata to the population uh and
the distribution is fair and equitable
to everybody
at this time i'm only sharing those
allocations with the states
so that they can do their micro planning
and we can ensure
a good constant flow of
to the entire united states of america
thank you next question please
our next question comes from katie
thomas from the new york times
katie your line is open i just wondered
what the total
um estimate is for how many millions of
doses will go out that first week is it
still six point four million
so six four six point four million is
where i snapped the chalk line
right because that was available uh at
the time
you know over two weeks ago uh and then
what we did is i pulled some off
for some reserve good army general
officer planning
right so that we make sure that in case
we
uh need to react to some situation we
had some reserve
and then i split the remaining doses
which was six million doses in half
and then we did the allocations
accordingly our plan
is to distribute the first dose to the
american people based on allocation
uh and then 21 days for pfizer uh later
we'll ship the second dose
and eventually for modernity it'll be 28
days later
but snap the chalk line 6.4 pulled off
some reserve divided in half
distributed the first half will
distribute
when eua is approved that is the method
that we're using
uh for the initial distributions
eventually
we will become much more confident uh in
our manufacturing our distribution
process
state handling etc and then the
requirement for reserve
won't be necessary uh at the total
amount that i'm pulling off now
thank you next question our next
question comes from candice troy from ap
candace your line is open
hi thanks for taking the questions um
can you give an update on the status of
the data use agreement
whether those final a handful of
jurisdictions have signed off on them
and then secondly as more vaccines come
online how are you planning
for scenarios where people might hold
out for a particular vaccine
for example everyone wanting the jj
one-shot vaccine and
leaving providers with stockpiles of two
dose vaccines
why don't you start off general and then
we'll turn to dr slowly for the second
question
so uh first one d uh euas
64 jurisdictions reminder 50 states
eight territories five our six
metropolitan cities
as well as five federal agencies we are
down to our last
three uh in fact we are in
communications with three states right
now
and we think we'll have them completed
today or tomorrow
is what i was briefed this morning i
feel very good about that
i have personally talked to all three uh
states about this and um i feel good
about it
um thank you
yeah so it's a it's an important
question the answer to
which can only be conceptual until we
actually know the performance of the
of the next vaccine now uh what
the criteria to be taken into account
are
the actual efficacy level that
the vaccine has i hope that
most vaccines that we will have will be
in the high 80s or 90 percent
there is a there is a there is a a
perception
uh associated with that that's important
and not to be neglected
but if there if there was a gradient on
efficacy
i i think it would make sense to give
the highest fxe vaccine to those who
have
the highest morbidity and mortality from
the disease
and the slightly lower efficacy if that
was to be the case
to a more healthy younger population i
think the second point
is the actual as i said the performance
the performance of the vaccine
in terms of uh safety profile a vaccine
with more
acceptable reactorgenicity would need to
go into populations that have the higher
benefit so again those that have more
severe disease consequences
and the vaccine that is milder may need
to go into
a lower risk population
and then frankly pragmatism which is
those availability the way we designed
our strategy has been to
give ourselves the opportunity to have
different vaccines
with different performance on the one
hand and spread our risk
in case some of them fail or are delayed
but secondly
to accumulate vaccine doses faster than
with just one supplier
by having different vaccines accumulate
different doses through different
manufacturing sites
thank you next question
our next question comes from graham
ferdano
from buzzfeed graham your line is open
hi it's dan vergano with buzzfeed news i
have uh
two questions i guess uh one for dr
slowly which is
how would you compare the side effect
profiles you're seeing in the pfizer and
moderna uh
numbers to other vaccines that people
might take that you've seen maybe the
flu vaccine and others
uh the second thing is uh maybe for
general purner or secretary azar
um i'm really just urging you to create
a dashboard with the distribution
numbers not just
keeping the states to reassure people
that's been very helpful to all of us in
the news business
not really a question just an
observation thank you for that and uh
the the feedback on the dashboard
question and i'll work with general
purno on
looking at that dr slawy right so
i would say the vaccine that has a the
closer
uh local reactor reactorgenicity and
systemic reactorgenicity i use the word
reactogenicity not the word safety
because
frankly safety it's all the same and
they're all
safe but the vaccines with this similar
local
and systemic reactor dynasty which is
injection site tenderness redness pain
headache a little bit of fever all of
the above
resolving within 24 to 36 hours for
immunization
about 10 15 percent having what's called
grade 3 which is not the maximum grade
grade 4 is the maximum
but grade 3 is is significant clearly
noticeable
uh 10 15 percent so the vaccine that's
closest to that is shingrix
another vaccine with very very high
efficacy probably there is no free lunch
if you have a very good immune response
you notice it
but it's not a safety issue it's uh
it's actually an immunogenicity marker
and shingles as i understand shingrix is
as i understand
is uh is so effective and
enormously used to the extent that the
competitor vaccine has been withdrawn
from the market
with no issues whatsoever thank you next
question please
our next question comes from carl
o'donnell from reuters news
carl your line is open
hi carl o'donnell from reuters um
you know just just curious with uh with
the vaccine doses you know likely to be
again being administered soon do you
guys have a plan
for um you know who who will receive
that
that first vaccine that's going to be
done publicly if you
have any sense of where that dose will
be administered or you know
what what type of person will receive at
a health care worker a front line worker
or something like that just curious if
you have any any planning
on that well now you make me feel as if
we should
general so we've been so focused on
speed getting it out and
deferring to the governors we have we
have been deferring to the governors and
we've been
deferring to the jurisdictions in the
cities and so
we probably do need to uh make a make a
plan for
you know who's going to get it first
visibly as secretary azar said
dr salawi said i apologize i'm putting
words
and i've said uh we're all going to be
available
uh if it's appropriate uh at the time to
be
uh to receive the shot and we're all
more than comfortable of getting it
um you know on tv et cetera but we want
to work through um
you know fair and equitable distribution
and the decisions by the governors
um the territories and you know the
mayors of the cities accordingly
uh and and it's just an important
balance of not uh
showing favoritism uh but making sure
that the people
that um you know asip um has identified
get the vaccine first in their
priorities
as the general mentioned i've i've i've
made clear to the team as i've made
clear publicly to the media and
otherwise that i will gladly get the
first uh first
first shot first vaccination just to
demonstrate the american people my
supreme confidence in the integrity of
the process the quality of the vaccines
and that i wouldn't ask the american
people to do something that i wouldn't
be willing to do myself
right next question please
our next question comes from john
collins from science magazine
john your line is open hi thanks for
taking my call i just wanted to clarify
something about the pfizer vaccine that
dr slowly said
i don't think you were implying that
people should just get one dose
so i just wanted to clarify that point
and the second the question i have
is about the data coming from russia
and from china of efficacy in press
releases
but if they were to apply for euas from
the fda and were to receive them would
the u.s government purchase
those vaccines and distribute them when
there's a shortage of supply of other
vaccines
i will answer the second question then
turn to dr slowly about the dosage
anybody is welcome if they are subject
to an ind under the fda's
clinical trial practices have conducted
their research
consistent with the human subject
research protection laws of the united
states and relevant treaties
to submit their data to apply for
registration for emergency use
authorization or biologic license with
the food and drug administration where
it would receive full consideration
but that would require as the fda is
demonstrating
by consideration of the pfizer and
moderna vaccine
complete and utter transparency and
availability of
all data related to the clinical trials
it's important to remember the fda
is looking under the hood literally
examining every line of data
every patient every patient identified
in there
uh to look through and confirm the
quality of the data
so they're open for business but you'd
have to comply with our rules to protect
patient safety
dr yeah i think it's a really important
point he said mr secretary because that
is one of the compelling or most
important rationales
of the time it's taking the fda actually
goes back into the raw data
and re-analyzes the data rather than
interpret uh a table for instance it's
out there i'm not suggesting anybody
else has done something wrong i'm just
describing how the fda does it and john
thank you very much for
asking for that clarification i'm
absolutely not suggesting
that the vaccine should be a one dose
vaccine because the observation of that
high efficacy was only over a period of
uh actually ten eight days
or nine days in the case of pfizer and
is only over a period of three weeks
maybe in the case of moderna
it's very encouraging to say super fast
onset of protection the second dose
is a full part of the label if the
vaccines are approved
it consolidates the immunity to to the
uh into the patients against covet 19
and that's the data that shows
long-lasting
at least over a few months uh immunity
and i expect it to be very long-lasting
but so
people should not take the vaccine as a
one dose vaccine
we do have the jansen's vaccine that is
being tested as a one dose vaccine
where the follow-up will be long enough
to assess that we're not observing you
know a micro
event but rather long term
one could ask the question why not run
fxc trials with the one dose vaccine of
the modern vaccine or the pfizer vaccine
that would be a valid question of course
timing
would be a big challenge dr salada can i
actually interject and ask a follow-up
question because i i get this one from
the media a lot and i think it'd be
helpful to have your perspective there
the question often comes up with the
pfizer 21 days
modern of 28 days to the second booster
shot that one would get
how precise is that on the 21 or 28 days
when a patient comes back if they were
to come say the 22nd day
23rd obviously we want everyone as close
to that as the the prescribed days as
possible but
could you describe for the media just
the interactions there
so there are there is the regulatory
answer and there is a scientific
observations i think the regulatory
answer is a vaccine is approved
on a 0-21 days or 0-28 days and that's
what should be done
now what does the science say around
that that precision is not
that important what we know with many
other vaccines is that the more
you space the two doses of vaccine
the better immune response you get after
the second dose but the trade-off is
that you have a weaker
potentially weaker protection between
the two doses
so when you're dealing with the disease
that has low incidence
that's okay because your risk of
contracting it is low
in between the doses so for instance
zero six months is better than zero two
months
is better than zero one months is
probably
slightly better than zero 21 days but
if there is significant transmission of
disease as is the case here
we should absolutely get the second dose
exactly as has been studied
thank you very much next question please
our next question comes from islam ahmed
from
asp your line is open um
hi thank you so much for doing this um
dr flowey i was wondering
um what you made of the um in the
vaccine on the the data that showed
um the four cases of bell's palsy is
that
something to watch out for moving
forward is how concerned are you about
that potentially
or at all and um the second
question was um are we fairly confident
at this time
that um we will see an immune
uh memory b-cell response and
so that the immune system will mount uh
antibodies further on
down the line or do we just not know
that yet thank you
so i think the the first question on on
safety is
whichever are the serious adverse events
of interest of which
policy would be won for instance on the
pfizer
strategy as it's now public there are
three
active pharmacovisions observation
studies
one the classic pharmacovigilance where
physicians or or
subjects patients called back into the
company
one that uses the va and the department
of defense
uh data sets on on on on subjects
immunized
and one an active healthcare worker
focused twenty thousand subjects
follow-up city over three years that
will detect
any significant adverse events i think
here
large number and long-term follow-up is
the key
and the capacity to compare to an
appropriate baseline
is the other key and and frankly the
appropriate baseline
is slightly challenging in the sense
that it's a new baseline
because the pandemic itself has changed
the baseline frequency of a number of
events into the population over the last
10 months so
it's very important to take a recent
almost concomitant baseline
as to the memory question all the data
generated with the messenger rna vaccine
in small animal and large animal and
with
other vaccines that i'm very familiar
with as i was on the board of moderna
before
it's very clear that you establish a
very robust long-lasting memory response
also assessed by by detecting memory
cells
and importantly looking at the recoil
response the uh
the immunoglobulin isotypes all the
markers needed to tell you you have a
robust t cell response and you have a
robust memory response
and i i think these vaccines
therefore will have long-term memory and
the protection induced after one dose
in the presence well in the absence of
detectable neutralizing antibodies
in my view is another demonstration that
this vaccine
best way to protect against this vaccine
disease
is actually really a faster kinetic
immune response
it's it's a race between the speed of
replication of the virus
and the speed of the immune response
mounting if you are old
have a weak immune system and your
immune response is
slow it will be very intense but it's
slow
by the time it intensifies you have a
lot of virus load have lots of cell
infected
you are in trouble if your immune
response is fast
you're asymptomatic or you're just
totally cleared and i think that's what
we
i would hypothesize would be established
in most people immunized is memory that
gives a faster immune response
and therefore long-lasting protection
thank you
next question please
do we have another question yes uh
my apologies the next question comes
from john jose bloomberg
news
hi thanks uh can you just clarify um
on the uh numbers and initial shipments
going out
just so we have it right um it sounds
like of the 6.4 million
by their doses 400 000 will be held in
reserve and then
half of the remaining six will be held
for second dose reserves so
three million initial stops uh will go
out
uh in the first round and then it is the
goal still to have 20 million people
vaccinated in december
so the answer to the second question
is we believe that there is there will
be enough vaccine available for 20
million first vaccinations in the month
of december
uh let me ask general purner though on
the actual precise numbers from the
first distribution trial
yeah so i rounded it to the question so
i apologize
so as 6.4 uh i pulled 500 000 for the
reserve
uh and then i divided the remaining
which meant 2.9
uh initial first dose and 2.9 second
dose
uh i apologize i did round for the for
the response of the question
the exact number is 6.4 pulled 500 000
2.9 first dose 2.9 second dose
next question please the next question
is from tom
powell washington times tom go ahead
hi uh tom howell with the washington
times uh we talked about how the recent
pfizer data showed there was protection
after the first dose
it sounds like you're still planning to
hold back half the doses to ensure
supply but
has there been any late breaking
consideration of just giving all the
initial doses and then
hoping that pfizer ramps up its
manufacturing in time
uh to have it available within a
reasonable amount of time
especially given what dr slowly said
about how it doesn't have to be
exactly 21 days or you know for that
second dose
thanks yeah so tom thanks and i'll ask
the the general the doctor to
to please add any color commentary on
this but um
because the eua applications and hence
the label from the fda
would likely we assume include both the
first dose followed by the second dose
we do believe whether from a held back
reserve
or from ongoing expected production of
vaccine
we believe there needs to be in our mind
an available dose for that second
administration
of the vaccine so we have done
calculations
of both what we are getting now what we
expect to get now
and what the production lines show
should be coming
and that's built into our forecast of
what we believe we need to hold back
and as the general said as we get more
experience on
quality control on the production we'll
get greater confidence of course in
in the level of supply reserve we hold
back for that second dose administration
but we will not distribute a vaccine
knowing that the booster will not be
available
either from reserve supply by us or from
ongoing expected predicted production
and we are already working with the
manufacturers to maximize
the full scale of their production so
that's built into our forecasts
i first i completely agree i
never suggested we should take a one
dose vaccine i did specifically say
the trade-off when you space is you may
your protection may go down
it would be i think a mistake an
unacceptable mistake
to knowingly distribute a vaccine
in non-respect of the label that would
actually
i think drive the hesitation around the
use of the vaccine high
so at least as an operation that's never
something we would recommend should be
done
we need to comply with how the vaccines
were tested and be optimally used
i think the second point is that
unfortunately the mathematics are
misleading
the numbers we share with you are
monthly numbers
right 40 million this month 50 million
next month
but that's not how life happens life
happens is the 40 million this month
is 2 million this week 5 million next
week
3 million the week after 7 million the
week after
and therefore it's not a bolus it's a
rolling number
and therefore if we were the only way i
can tell you we played the
the mathematics and the modeling of that
for a whole week
because there is there is almost an
ethical question there
that we wanted to make sure was the
trade-off
and the trade-off is about one to one
and a half million
people vaccinated with the risk of not
giving
the second dose knowingly to people at
the time they should have received it
and we decided that's not a risk we
should take
maybe maybe by the middle of the month
of january or
early february when we have had five six
weeks of rolling
high cadence manufacturing and that we
see that
you know things are rolling perfectly
we may and i i did say it in other
settings
i have never in 30 years
seen the launch of a new product without
having built up a stock before
in industry and there is a reason why
industry takes that financial hit
it's because we always know particularly
with biologicals
things could happen doesn't mean they
will happen but they could happen and
therefore you build a stock in this case
we have a pandemic
we need to people save people's life
we're going to roll
vaccine doses as they come but we're not
certain
they will come exactly as per plan and
as we've said
you know biologic protein manufacturing
it uh
it it can be as much art form as it
is science and dr slawy i think you've
used the phrase before that
that proteins are moody and we have to
be very careful on production that's
really been one of the core elements
of operation warp speed i think really
one of the genius elements behind it
was moving from clinical trial lot
size production to commercial scale
production
early on in the development period
through the
logistics manufacturing and financial
heft that we've been able to bring to
the table
to act to try to actually get there
because there are often
so many failures in the normal
commercial biopharma industry
in that move from clinical trial scale
to commercial scale
exercise the system get that done but
still be cautious
especially in the early weeks and months
of vaccine distribution
because quality control issues strillity
issues they happen
in biologic manufacturing if i if i
could mr secretary just add two points
to that
and i agree wholeheartedly with both
comments
um one i i use the term snap the chalk
line
you know it is about ensuring that the
number
that we allocate against allows the
jurisdictions to do the detailed
planning
on the locations and the quantity they
want sent to those locations
right so that we assure efficient and
effective
uh distribution and eventual use of the
vaccine
the second point i would tell everybody
is is if your plan is based on
perfection
i can guarantee you execution
will not equal perfection so you have to
uh
put things in place to mitigate uh where
you're vulnerable
and to allow us to you know adjust and
make sure
that everybody who gets their first dose
can get their second dose
we have time for one last question
okay the last question comes from
rebecca robbins new york times
rebecca your line is open
thank you for taking my question my
question pertains to
the nursing home effort by cbs
and walgreens could you tell me when
that will begin
or if the first shipments and the first
allocations that states will be making
will be going exclusively to hospitals
and
health care centers and whether the
nursing home effort
will start later thank you general sure
so i just want to really applaud the
great work by the cdc
uh cvs walgreens and the states in this
effort right we
roughly six weeks ago maybe two months
ago i brought it as a course of action
to them to prioritize figure out a
solution
that can be implemented nationally that
would best
service uh provide support to these
facilities
and i would tell you i i've received
incredible updates
and i'm excited about the plan number
two
as we've talked about the plan uh we're
implementing the state's plans to their
priorities
so their determination of i would like
it to go to the healthcare or long-term
healthcare facilities
has to be identified first as many as
36 states have already told the cdc
as of my update this morning that they
want initial
dosage to go long-term health care
facilities
the cdc walgreens and cbs
are working those plans right now
the third thing is is that it is a not
as easily
executed as easily said the amount of
work that has to be done
in collaboration and coordination with
the actual sites
right understanding the patients that
are there
making sure that uh all people
uh are briefed and notified and people
that care for those people
are notified all that collaboration has
to occur
making sure the right sites uh to
administer inside of
the facilities are ready uh and that
coordination
but that detailed work has been done uh
and we are going to be ready to
implement
when the first wave goes out in
accordance with the state's plans
over great well um to the members the
media i hope you are finding these
weekly briefings helpful we intend to
continue them i also hope yesterday that
you were able to watch the
vaccine distribution summit meeting
where you got to hear from
leaders at cvs and walgreens talking
about their plans on nursing homes but
also more general retail distribution
and how we're leveraging
the the normal vaccine and flu just flu
vaccine distribution systems that we
have to get to hear from
these great logistics and distribution
companies mckesson
fedex ups who literally showed you
the materials they're using to shipping
mckesson showing the actual
kits that they've put together in our
direction of pp syringes needles diluent
to be able to administer vaccine and
getting to hear from some of our great
governors about how detailed
the micro distribution planning has been
at the state level working with general
purdue's team and the cdc
to make that happen i just hope you'll
assist us in getting word out to the
american people so that they can have a
high degree of confidence as general
purna and each of those corporate
leaders said
we're leveraging what already works
every year in our system to distribute
and vaccinate
hundreds of millions of vaccinations
every year using the tried and true
using the systems that we know work or
as they all said
this is what we do leverage that don't
try to build something new and different
we have enough
we have enough variables on execution
that we're managing
through this covid pandemic use the
tried and true there and i hope you'll
help us with getting the word out so
people will have confidence
that our military our cdc our states our
governors our private sector
they know how to do this they'll get
this job done so thank you all very much
and have a good rest of the week
that concludes today's briefing please
send any follow-up questions to our
press office at media
hhs.gov and have a good rest of the day
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]